there's no doubting the momentum behind
Liz Trust
cheered on an extra last night she
delivered her latest pledge to the party
faithful this is partly about
challenging not just the treasury
Orthodoxy but the White Horse Orthodoxy
and getting things done and I'm prepared
to break up eggs to make The Omelette
today though a policy misstep has
unraveled Liz truss pledged a civil
service shake-up that would save 11
billion pounds a year 8.8 billion of
which would come by adjusting wages for
regional jobs effectively paying
government workers Less in poorer parts
of the country
the backlash came almost immediately
well the policy of cutting the pay for
Northern teachers police officers and
civil servants seems like a Surefire way
to lose the next general election and
the idea that the north should some
people in the north should somehow be
paid less compared to counterparts in
the Southeast for doing the same job is
completely counter-intuitive to the
leveling up agenda that as experts warn
it to make the savings a plan would
impact not just government departments
but teachers nurses police officers
allies rallied to defend it we need a
smaller civil service we have 91 000
more people working for the Civil
Service than we did in 2016 we need to
get back to the 2016 level that on its
own will save about three and a half
billion pounds potentially more but it's
not just the civil services it's list
trust is also talking about anyone's pay
for the governments that involves
teachers that involves police officers
involves nurses doesn't it that's not
that's not the plan the discussion at
the moment is around is around civil
servants soon after there came this a
statement from Team trust saying over
the last few hours there's been a
willful misrepresent annotation of our
campaign current levels of public sector
pay will absolutely be maintained
anything to suggest otherwise is simply
wrong our hard-working Frontline staff
are the Bedrock of society and there'll
be no proposal taken forward on Regional
pay boards the civil servants or public
sector workers a U-turn seized on by
team sunac this uh policy would have
been disastrous because it would have
meant that many public sector workers
nurses police officers and others would
have faced a potential serious pay cut
Liz trust reportedly lobbied for
Regional pay when she worked in the
treasury four years ago a source close
to Russia sunax campaign said the policy
wasn't a mistake it was the timing that
was a big part of the problem talking
about public sector pay in the middle of
a cost of living crisis team trust
publicly point to Richie sunax u-turns
but privately her allies admit that this
has been badly handled this was the
first real stumble in Liz truss's
campaign and it comes on the week where
ballots arrive on Tory doorsteps this is
unlikely to derail Liz truss's campaign
she Remains The Firm favorite but it has
raised questions about the competence
and the Judgment of the woman likely to
be the next prime minister Ali Ford skew
Sky News
and just to alert you that later this
week Rishi sunak and Liz truss will both
take part in a live special program the
battle for number 10 here on Sky News it
will be hosted by K Burley on Thursday
at eight o'clock